[Music]
don't be fooled these gruesome burn
wounds are actually fake creating
effects like this for TV and movies is a
rigorous time-consuming process that
involves complex prosthetics and makeup
some of which are actually lit on fire
and a close attention to detail but the
result is worth the wait when a director
needs a character who's been lit on fire
or maybe the victim of a chemical spill
or explosion they'll go to someone like
Ben Bornstein a special makeup effects
artist who runs taking shapes to do
Bornstein has done all sorts of special
makeup effects work on movies like The
Departed in the fighter and he's done
several types of burn wounds for shows
like blind spot and Gotham Bornstein
brought in stunt performer Kachina
Dekker to undergo this transformation
any good Hollywood makeup artist knows
that the actor's comfort is crucial how
can we make it nice for them and not as
crazy and disruptive to their
performance our job is to enhance them
performance and that can be done without
sacrificing realism the first step for
Bornstein is figuring out what kind of
burn it is and what the damage should
look like in a hypothetical scenario for
this demonstration the character has
escaped a burning building but not
unscathed
this is a fresh burn wound and the
character hasn't had a chance to seek
medical attention there's all these
things that go in the story that we have
to think about from Step A to Z so say
like you got burned by an iron on your
face like a curling iron you got to
think how hot was it how long was it on
how long did it sit in your face we
don't think about the reality of it
would the skin bubble would it come up
with the iron would it be a piece I want
this to look like it she just got out of
an explosion there are some cheap easy
ways for Bornstein to go about this
methods he would call out of the kit for
a burned arm he can use a burn transfer
tattoo it's kind of like a bazooka Joe
tattoo you'd get when you're a kid but
on steroids that lasts all day these are
great for makeup artists they stay on
all day indeed minimal touch-ups one of
the toughest parts of a makeup artists
job is making sure the cast looks exact
the same on every single day this method
is great for continuity while efficient
these tattoos are two-dimensional so
they work better for background
characters another easy and effective
method using glutes and bald cap plastic
a k-paul DS and actually lighting it on
fire there are plenty of ways to make
simple materials
look gruesome so now I'm just cutting a
sheet of bald-cap vinyl and it's gonna
make a little weird gross membrane on
top of the burn that Adams painting
so we'll just glue this on and we'll
blend up the edge and have KY jelly
inside the middle of it so we can see
some depth and translucency to give it
more of an effect
Borenstein cannon will go much bigger
for a scenario like this after all this
is supposed to be a hero character
another term for the main character so
Bernstein and his team made some large
prosthetic pieces before starting on
them he needed to do some research so he
could nail down a few key things texture
and color that research can take strange
forms like looking at pictures of burnt
meat the textures are cool but it's not
you know it's not there look at this
gorgeous look at that detail look at
those colors if you can see all the
black are really the only raised areas
here so we're looking at what could be a
piece or even just like maybe the ball
these stuff that we put on top of just
paint all this little fatty area and
like all the yellow golden yellow I love
all that and to really notice that the
edges aren't black it's the deepest
parts of it are black like if you look
at this is just blacks little spots and
then there's a ring of red and then it's
black way above it we could almost even
probably use some of her tones in there
but I love this picture for reference I
think it's beautiful you can see that
influence in the prosthetic pieces look
at all the cracks and char and the
dominance of red and black like with any
prosthesis
it started with a head cast Bornstein
used that cast to create a sculpture of
deckert's head from there they got a
plaster version of her head and a rubber
mold negative that negative was used to
build the silicone pieces his team
sculpted away to get the perfect texture
while working they had to keep in mind
that this was supposed to be a fresh
burn I
opposed to an age scar like it just
happened
and she's still smoldering but she's put
out press these like this are needed
especially if there is going to be a lot
of close-up shots of a burned character
you can't fake that you need the
textures there everything had to fit and
be blended in perfectly and follow the
right color palette so looked like a
truly fresh char the team also had to
build around her wardrobe
they knew what costume she would wear
and that will be torn up by the
explosion while they didn't have to make
prosthesis for her entire body they did
need to decide if there would be visible
wounds in areas where skin was exposed
if there were open areas left blank
where there should be a burn it would
make the overall performance less
convincing we'll glue this to her maybe
we'll fuse it with an appliance or
something there's a boot line it's good
gonna do a number on you Katrina may be
dope here was just as much a factor I
want the piece to lay flat with an edge
would blend the edge then the hair will
go over it solve this hair has to go
this way to maximize comfort for the
star they saved some of the least
comfortable prosthetic pieces for last
they started early by gluing on the big
chest piece blending it into the skin is
key this scaly piece could have been
placed on deckert's leg but the team
decided it made more sense on her arm I
love a little black I love it and
remember those burned up sheets they
were put on alongside the two prosthetic
pieces layered and blended in so
sometimes it was hard to tell the
difference between the two they decided
to rely more heavily on the burned
plastics for her legs while sticking to
the color palette and directly painting
on yellow wherever they could so let's
see a big hole we're gonna paint that
then this massive piece went right on
Deckard stomach notice how the edges
were peeled off and the piece was
blended into her skin the final
prosthetic piece they attached was the
face piece which only covered the left
half this was most of the meet of the
build was making his piece hurt you'll
come through this and then I think we'll
put a black char to connect it while
they could have covered the ear to make
it look like it fell off Bornstein
thought it would have been too obvious
and instead liked the idea of keeping it
on but dirtying it up he also had to
consider that the eyebrow would have
been burned off
so Bornstein simply painted over it so
it wouldn't show up under the facepiece
there are lots of different final
touch-ups to make sure they looked as
fresh as possible I think we should put
blood but in little spots fit other
materials like clean dirt added to the
color palette the final piece was also
the most uncomfortable contact lenses
this stage required a lens technician in
the end everything was so well blended
together it's hard to tell what's paint
and what's silicone the real winner of
the day I think it was honestly the
glass and sheets that we put on her it
really it really did sell it I wanted to
mix kind of that reality with like some
superhero look where half her head
my hair is missing the fact that we
decided to take the sculpture up into
the hairline because it was just here it
just doesn't look right so we want it to
go like the extra mile and have a wrap
around her head applying the makeup to
taking it all off took over four hours
computers and visual effects have
enhanced the work of makeup and special
effects artists if you marry the two we
can like recess crazy areas of the face
or body that we can't do with makeup
we'd have to make a fake head of it
so why didn't Bernstein and his team
just create the burns using CGI
especially when as is the case of to
face in the dark night the minimal
practical makeup might just be covered
in a CGI layer because practical effects
won't just give you a better movie but
also a better performance we can bring
something to the table that looks
organic that looks real and enhance the
actress performance if they have nothing
on them maybe they won't a mote as much
maybe their look maybe they're laying in
a hospital bed and they're looking at
their hand maybe that will help them cry
more on camera we're giving them tools
to work with but most importantly we're
giving the camera tools to work with
so they don't have to do it in
post-production
[Music]